between the 1960s and the 1980s tens of
thousands of Nigerian children were
fostered out by their parents to white
working-class families in the UK this
informal system became known as farming
this is one of their stories it was
during the 1900s when thousands of
immigrants moved to England the
government and the public became really
concerned at the level of immigrants
arriving in the country some of them
even threatened to start a killing spree
if the immigrants keep on coming without
getting properly checked the public were
worried about a shortage of basic
resources and available jobs when the
immigration doesn't stop a gang called
the right-wing groups clashes with the
immigrants while the police fail to gain
control the violence makes the poor
Nigerians leaves even worse as they are
already struggling to adopt the foreign
culture to let their children have a
better life the Nigerians are fostering
them to White family while they spend
day and night saving enough to take care
of their kids in future this practice
becomes really common and thousands of
kids are living this life one of them is
6 months old in n his parents can't take
care of him because of the financial
burden and give him to the foster
parents named ingred and Jack once they
complete their studies and get a stable
job anan's parents promis to take him
back to Nigeria many years pass away and
Anon has grown up into an obedient young
boy ingred has taken in many other
Nigerian kids and charges a small fee
from their parents but anan's parents
haven't returned yet and they also left
his two sisters here ingred loves kids
but she and her friends find Anan a
little weird he talks really less and
likes playing behind the sofa with his
Imaginary Friends he is also a little
insecure and always yearns for extra
attention instead of understanding him
ingred takes advantage of the poor kid
she takes him to a pawn shop and asks
him to bring out an expensive necklace
if he wants to be mommy's favorite and
eaten does his said but the shopkeeper
catches him seeing this ingred hits him
and pretends like she didn't know later
she tells aniton to steal the necklace
when no one is looking Anan does that
too so he can get some affection from
ingred but the selfish woman gives the
necklace to her other favorite child
thus breaks anan's heart but he doesn't
say a word though ingred loves kids she
isn't a noble woman and uses the kids to
get funds from the government she is not
the only one doing this this fostering
practice is now called farming and it
has increased drastically in the last
few weeks so the government is looking
for other solutions they can't provide
this much funds so they are tracking
down the biological parents if they
can't be found the kids will be given
away to the closest relatives ingred
gets panicked to hear that as her whole
business will shut down she explains
that the kids are born in England so
they shouldn't be forced to leave the
government gives some extension so
ingred continues to bring up the kids
meanwhile enitan is struggling to become
a part of the community he is not loved
by ingred and doesn't have any friends
in the neighborhood the white kids bully
him and even make their dog bite poor
anyon ingred gets really angry and asks
her husband Jack to talk with the white
kid's parents instead of doing that Jack
kicks inan out of the house and tells
him to to not return until he has beaten
up the kids who bullied him such harsh
treatment is torturing the little kid's
mind and he can't live normally after a
few days Anan goes out to play with his
sisters and spots a rainbow so he
immediately makes a wish as he returns
home he meets his parents who came to
take him back after reaching their
Hometown aniton is introduced to
everyone but he seems a little distanced
he grew up trying to fit in the British
community and now he has to deal with
another new world anan's grandfather
suggests that they should perform their
family rituals to welcome the kids all
of them are quite weird and they even
Pierce anon's chest with sharp blades
aniton is getting disgusted by his own
family and doesn't interact with any of
them he isolates himself and doesn't
even speak in the school when the
teacher punishes him aniton snatches the
stick and beats the teacher it's been 6
months aniton hasn't spoken a word and
he has been expelled from school Thrice
his father gives up and decides to send
him back to the foster home his mother
begs to let Inon stay but his father
just wants him to lead a normal life the
parents keep the two girls while aniton
gets back to the foster home ingred and
her friends make fun of Anton's family
rituals and he gets really embarrassed
he locks himself in the washroom and
washes his face really hard he believes
that his black color is dirt and he can
wash it off to become white when it
doesn't work enitan puts loads of talcum
powder on his face and gets in the
streets he thought that the white kids
would accept him now but they just made
fun of him several years pass away in
such miserable circumstances and Anon is
already 16 he is studying in high school
but his trauma keeps following him he
hates his own race and mocks his teacher
Miss Dao just because she is black he
also fights with his classmates and gets
suspended at home ingred degrades him
for being the worst kid she ever brought
up an eon just keeps wandering around
looking for a place where he fits in
Miss Deo spots him near the school and
invites him for a quick conversation she
asks about things like his friends and
his dreams Anon says he has a lot of
friends but but they all are imaginary
he never planned to become a great man
but he likes to draw this breaks Miss
dapos and she realizes how lonely aniton
is before she can talk to him more he
leaves all of a sudden aniton stops by
in a public park and admires the lovely
flowers grown there he takes out his
notebook to draw a picture of the
flowers but he gets interrupted by a
group of skinhead British men who call
themselves Tilbury skins they are led by
a creepy man named Levi who continuously
insults anon's color and origin the
insensitive goons beat up aniton and
tear off his clothes then they suggest
different torturing punishments for the
innocent boy just because he is black
Levi has a different idea he takes out
white paint spray and puts it over
anan's face then WR there motto on the
wall that says keep Britain white
meanwhile ingred is busy taking care of
her other foster kids she has no idea
what aniton is going through he doesn't
return home and doesn't go to school
either he stays in the park and waits
for a chance to take his revenge
as the skin heads pass by aniton shouts
at them and takes out a hammer to beat
them Levy Smiles at him as he knows Anan
doesn't have the courage to stand
against them misso and other students
witnessed the incident but they can't
stop the skin heads from beating up an
Eaton this time they do not let him go
and threaten him to act like their pet
dog the Tilbury skins aren't any good to
their own people either they don't have
any degree or jobs and live by robbing
different shops they make a neat and
help them in these dirty tasks even the
police have no control over them as they
are a really big gang Anan just quietly
follows them and looks forward to
getting accepted by them one day that's
all he ever wishes for he wants to be
one of the whites but the skin heads are
only interested in playing with his
feelings they make him do bizarre tasks
like killing an innocent Pig Anan is
scared but he keeps following orders
Levi brainwashes him every day and makes
anaton chance their group name and all
their abusive mots against the black
people the only one who truly car cares
for him is Miss Dapo she even goes to
meet ingred to talk about anaton but
ingred responds rudely and tells Miss
Dapo to mind her own business on the
other side Inon shaves his head and
wears clothes like the skin heads to
become a part of them Levy knows Anan is
desperate for acceptance so he always
keeps testing his loyalty he instructs
enitan to help them abuse Miss Dapo they
throw her on the ground and beat her
brutally she kept asking for help but
anaton didn't dare to go against his
master also spots him with the gang but
she turns a blind eye to this incident
along with the Tilbury skins Anan
tortures other Nigerian immigrants every
day he even writes all the abusive
chants and comments on his bedroom walls
ingred tries to question him but Anan
doesn't bother to listen to her at all
and say that he is the law hearing this
ingred also humiliates him and says that
no one will ever accept him enitan
returns to the skin heads and keeps
abusing his own kind beside Tilbury
skins there's another gang in the town
called grey skins lead by by spika one
night when the Tilbury Skins are hanging
out in a bar spika and his men come to
meet them they aren't happy with Levi
keeping a black guy in his gang and
carrying around a snake around his neck
Levi doesn't care about Spa's opinion
and tells him to leave spika gets
triggered and returns with his men they
suddenly attack from all sides enidan
tries to defend his team and uses an
alcohol bottle to light fire on Spa's
body the police arrive and arrest all of
them after a night the Tilbury Skins are
set free but Enon is forced to stay till
his foster mother comes to pick him up
ingred wakes up in his bedroom when he
hears the skin heads shouting outside
his house ingred tells them to leave but
they want aniton they start breaking the
windows so aniton quietly comes out and
joins them while ingred keeps yelling at
him not to return again the Tilbury
skins have a face off with the gray
skins Levi stands at the front but the
opponent gang asks for Anon as he was
the one who burnt spika at first Tilbury
skins pretend to stand by Anan but after
a while they all leave poor Anan gets
severely injured and rushes to ask Levi
why he was left alone Levi laughs at him
and says he will not let the Tilbury
skins lead by a black man enitan did so
much but he is still not welcomed in the
gang he can't stand the Betrayal and
proceeds to kill Levy afterward he takes
the snake and shouts Tilbury skins the
skin heads refuse to let him be the
leader so aniton takes shelter in an
abandoned workshop and considers the
snake as his best friend this doesn't
satisfy him enough so returns to his
foster home he hides behind the sofa
where he used to play with his Imaginary
Friends ingred calls the police and
aniton is thrown in prison he spends a
few days there till the lawyer arrives
who has called ingred and also Anton's
biological parents they put all the
blame on ingred and start arguing aniton
has lost his senses he beats his father
and the police officers to run away he
goes to check on his snake but it is
already dead aniton holds it tightly and
starts crying he keeps wandering ing on
the streets looking for his place but
cannot find it the Tilbury Skins are
informed that Anan is out of jail so
they gather to take revenge for their
leader murder before they can reach him
Enon hangs himself to get rid of his
miserable life he can't fight anymore
the police arrive at the spot and
immediately take the boy to the hospital
thankfully he survives once his injuries
are recovered he is sent to a
rehabilitation center miraculously his
Guardian there is none other than his
teacher Miss Dapo she tells him that his
parents have paid for his education he
will be free from all the legal charges
but in return he must study law like his
father aniton sits down in a corner and
says that he can't do it Miss Dapo
Comforts him and explains that he has
another chance to change his life and
this time he is not alone aniton
struggles to move on from his past but
he doesn't give up despite the
traumatizing memories haunting him
continuously aniton keeps on studying
after a few years he succeeded in
receiving a degree from a renowned
London University he reconciles with his
parents and also forgives his foster
mother now he is stepping towards a
bright future and has become an
inspiration for thousands like him you
fail only when you stop trying even the
darkest night has a morning you just
have to be patient determined and
possess a strong faith